democrats pursue new police standards
while promoting myths about how policing
actually works
the chauvin trial continues and the
biden administration hits the pause
button on the johnson and johnson
vaccine i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with the
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which if we have learned
anything over the past few years it is
that you cannot trust the big tech bros
with your information with your data
because here's the reality they may not
like you and then they use the data to
monetize their own platforms which don't
like you so why exactly would you give
your data
to them a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that private
but the internet has changed all of that
having a private life exposed for others
to see well that used to be something
only celebs worried about well now that
is you to keep your data private when
you go online do the same thing i do go
to expressvpn.com
did you know there are hundreds of data
brokers out there whose sole business is
to buy and sell your data the worst part
they don't have to tell you who you're
selling it to or get your consent
one of those data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip to
uniquely identify you
and your location but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server my ip address is masked
every time i turn expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers
that makes it much more difficult for
third parties to identify me and harvest
my data
the best part is how easy expressvpn is
to use no matter what device you're on
phone
laptop smart tv all you have to do tap
one button you're now protected so if
like me
you believe your data is your business
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com
ben get three extra months for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com and head on
over to expressvpn.com
to learn more alrighty so we are now in
the midst of this grand american
rethinking about the nature of policing
in the united states here's the reality
about policing
it's a tough dirty job and not very many
people want to do it and if you make it
tougher
and more dirty and more difficult to get
done very very few people want to do it
and that is precisely why you have seen
the murder rate rise 30 percent
in the course of one year we are now
re-entering 1960s
early 1970s crime territory that is not
where you want to be as a country
and the reason for that is we have
decided that we are now the experts
on how policing should work even though
very few of us have ever had to do any
policing
not only that we believe things that we
watch on tv
about how policing works so the same
exact people who will say things like
why don't you shoot to wound by the way
you know who said that
the president of the united states joe
biden back during the debates he was
like
why couldn't they just have shot to
wound in the case of jacob blake
it's like because you don't know
anything about how any of this works
right why is it that they they can't
just shoot him from a hundred yards away
with a taser
like all of this stuff is rooted in a
basic misunderstanding of how policing
works in the united states
and that misunderstanding combined with
the idea that america's police are
systemically racist
another notion that is simply false on
its face the idea that
america's police are just are
disproportionately and specifically
targeting black people for victimization
those two ideas combined lead to an
awful lot of bad policy
the latest bad policy comes courtesy of
the state of maryland
where over the objections of governor
larry hogan the state legislature
passed these sweeping police reforms
according to the new york times
maryland lawmakers voted on saturday to
limit police officers use of force
restrict the use of no knock warrants
and repeal the nation's first bill of
rights for law enforcement
so what exactly does all of that mean
well it means you ain't going to sign up
any more police officers in maryland is
really what it means
one section creates a new statewide use
of force policy and says that officers
who violate those standards
causing serious injury or death can be
convicted and sent to prison for up to
10 years
the standard says that force can be used
only to prevent an imminent threat of
physical injury to a person
or to effectuate a legitimate law
enforcement objective
well that is an awful lot of wiggle room
for prosecutors to go after cops
which is why the cops are opposing this
sort of stuff you can imagine an awful
lot of situations
in which the police have to do something
to effectuate an arrest
based on for example a a violated
warrant
and then the person dies and then the
cop is brought up on charges for really
having not done
anything wrong just being caught on tape
in a way that we don't particularly like
and we know this is happening across the
united states anyway the language there
is extremely broad and extremely vague
the policy also says that forests must
be quote necessary and proportional
well necessary and proportional is a
pretty tough standard because now you
have a bunch of civilians deciding
what exactly is necessary and
proportional police reform groups said
this is a much tougher standard than the
traditional reasonableness standard
which they said was not sufficient for
holding officers accountable for blatant
acts of violence
but reasonableness is rooted in the idea
that police officers have to actually
assess the situation on the ground
and then make a determination necessary
and proportional means
that unless something is quote unquote
strictly necessary you cannot do it well
who's to determine what is strictly
necessary
in a second i'm gonna explain why all of
these laws really are quite bad for
policing and why they're gonna be
horrible for public safety
also law enforcement agencies statewide
must establish a system to identify
police officers who are considered
likely to use excessive force
and restrain counsel or if needed
reassign them now that part is fine
right my guess is that larry hogan would
have signed that bill into law
but the legislature also repealed
maryland's law enforcement officer bill
of rights that was the nation's first
such law when it was enacted in the
1970s
it gave every officer statewide the
right to appeal discipline to a local
board
regardless of the city's wishes instead
lawmakers replaced those protections by
requiring every county to have a police
accountability board to receive
complaints of misconduct from the public
a problem with a lot of these police
accountability boards
is they are heavily politicized if you
can get enough people in positions of
power on the police accountability board
who don't like the police
you will just have a group of people
cramming down on the police completely
unworkable rules
civilians will have a role on
administrative charging committees that
will review the findings of law
enforcement agencies and recommend
discipline for officers
police chiefs will not be able to issue
disciplinary actions more lenient than
the levels recommended by those panels
also lawmakers limited the use of no
knock warrants
officers have said because of the
brianna taylor case
in that case that they actually didn't
announce their presence some witnesses
disagreed but no knock warrants are
sometimes necessary if you think that
the person who's inside the residence
is going to fire a gun at you if you
knock on the door
so these sorts of bills i mean there's a
reason why larry hogan who is not a
hardcore conservative
vetoed this bill and then it was passed
in spite of all of that and the reason
is
because the level of civilian
understanding of how policing works is
abysmal
truly awful just to take a perfect
example
over the past several nights we've had
these riots in brooklyn center
and they are full scale riots you have
people attacking police officers you've
had
the national guard having fire tear gas
at people you've seen people attempting
to break in and loot stores it's really
really ugly
it looks like a war zone in parts of
brooklyn center well yesterday the
brooklyn center mayor said
i don't believe officers need to have
weapons when they make arrests
i'm gonna need he's gonna need to show
his work on paper here for me to
understand
what nellie's talking about here i don't
believe that
officers need to necessarily uh
have weapons uh you know uh every time
they
they're they're making a traffic stop uh
or or engaged in uh
situations that don't necessarily call
for
uh for weapons we know that there are
other many other jurisdictions or even
around the world where
uh that is not you know necessarily the
case it's not needed
see one of the things that is very odd
about sort of the leftist worldview with
regard to policing
is the left wants a lot of very
stringent regulations on how you live
your life
and there aren't lots of regulations on
how cigarettes are sold for example or
they want heavy regulations
on how exactly you're able to operate
your vehicle they want heavy regulations
on virtually every area of life but they
refuse to acknowledge the reality of
regulations
which is that all regulations in the end
are enforced at the point of a
government gun
this is true with regards to your taxes
it is true with regard to environmental
protections
in the end if you resist arrest if you
refuse to obey the law there will be a
government gun at the end of it they
don't like the gun
so at the same time they want to promote
heavy regulations at the same time
they want to ensure that the government
has more power they shy away from the
idea that that power actually
exists so you have this bizarre
situation where the mayor of brooklyn
center
is now saying that if you pull somebody
over for drunk driving for example that
the police officer shouldn't have a
weapon okay well what happens when the
guy pops back in his car and takes off
you're supposed to stand there with
nothing in your hands how exactly is
that supposed to work
and the answer is they don't think about
how this stuff works because they don't
care how this stuff works
all of it is posturing it is all rooted
in a basic misconception
which is that policing is nice and happy
and that everything works out well
police officers have millions of
interactions with people every single
year
millions something like 4 million
interactions between the police and
civilians every single year
and those interactions are generally not
wonderful because nobody's having a good
day
when they interact with a cop police
officers know this
but again when you have civilians who
don't understand
how any of this works making the rules
and doing so on the basis of bad data
that is a bad thing now you should have
civilian or i'm not arguing that the
police should basically just quote
unquote control themselves that the
police should be the only
authority in how they use their force
that of course would be fascistic
you can't have armed wings of the
american government being the only
court of appeal however the sort of
loosening of regulations that you are
seeing by democrats
in terms of how you prosecute officers
the attempt to prevent officers from
doing their jobs at any sort of
expert level understanding on this sort
of stuff is really a problem
and it's going to lead to more death
there's a recent study that came out and
it showed
that in america's major cities the ones
that were that were riven by protests
from 2014 to 2019 ever since the
shooting of michael brown in ferguson
missouri
that the number of police avoidable
deaths according to this study
was something like 300 and the number of
total deaths
that were actually created in other
words there were 300 fewer deaths
because of
interactions between cops and civilians
or cops and suspects
but the number of total deaths in those
cities that were avoidable rose by
something like
6 000 because it turns out when you take
cops off the streets when you tell cops
not to do their job they won't do their
job
when they don't do their job bad things
happen some people on the left are at
least honest enough to go all the way
here
so obviously had rashida talib
suggesting it's time to abolish policing
in the united states overall jason
johnson on msnbc saying the exact same
thing
honestly if this is how democrats want
to play it go for it we'll see if
americans really feel
like they are so safe from their fellow
american that the police can just be
disbanded
i've been saying we need to abolish
american policing as it currently exists
it doesn't work you know the average
homicides that are actually solved by
police departments only about 35
you know the number of rapes and sexual
assaults that are sold by police
departments
you know less than 60 you know the
percentage
likelihood of being shot unarmed as a
black person is like five times as
likely than a white person
policing doesn't work the way we're
doing it right now
uh i have a question what does he think
the level of uh homicide
solving uh finding the the actual perp
in a homicide what do you think that
level would be if there were no police
would it be 35
or it would be zero is the great
obstacle to solving homicides
the police being bad at their jobs or is
it that a lot of people won't testify
and give actual witness evidence with
regard to homicides
getting rid of the police doesn't solve
the problem of homicide it creates more
homicides
if somebody is raped who do you go to in
this particular case
and the notion that black people are
being shot by the police
at five times the rate of white people
is just not true
okay statistically speaking that is not
i'm unaware of any stats that
demonstrate that black people on a per
capita level are being shot at five
times the rate of white people
that is that is a bizarre again
evidence-free statement so far as i'm
aware if somebody can disabuse me of
that i am happy to take a look at those
stats
in actuality something like 500 white
americans were shot by the cops between
january of 2020 and march of 2021.
okay so i i'm not and the number of
unarmed black men
according to the washington post who are
shot every year by the police
generally less than 30. but this is all
rooted in basic misunderstandings
of how policing works and also
rooted in a certain animus for the
police which results in just
lies to take an example remember that
whole jacob laycase
remember that case where a man was
called to a man
arrived at the site of his
ex-girlfriend's house and uh
who who had accused him of of penetrate
of rape with his finger
earlier on uh in the year i believe and
she called the police saying this guy is
back at the house and the police arrive
he resists arrest
he has a knife he reaches into the car
they shoot him
remember that joe biden and kamal harris
called that guy and talked about what
rough life
he had and how difficult it was for him
and how terrible the police were
well now it turns out that the police
officer who shot jacob blake last summer
is back on duty
because the kenosha police investigation
found no wrongdoing you know why because
there was no wrongdoing you know who
said there was no wrongdoing people who
knew anything about policing you know
who said there was wrongdoing
every single democrat everyone i'm
unaware of a democrat who said that
those police officers were entitled to
due process
and that even the tape was not
dispositive with regard to whether
the police officers had done something
wrong didn't matter resulted in riots
and kenosha
remember this it happened in the middle
of last year not that long ago
you see the same sort of myth-making
happening now happening now with regard
to the dante wright case
okay it is this was fairly obviously an
accident
by the police officer who will indeed be
and end up being charged for
manslaughter
a police officer drew a gun instead of a
taser which is an inexcusable mistake
and then shot
dante wright now there are additional
facts about dante wright that we are
learning about
that cast some serious doubt on the idea
that he is some sort of
wonderful person but that is not really
indicative
as to the crime committed by the officer
in question
it does it does really blow up the
narrative that when whenever you have
one of these situations whether it's
george floyd whether it's dante right or
whether it's jacob blake the initial
reaction the media are is always
this person is a wonderful tremendous
human
and all of the police are evil and
terrible two things can be true at once
one the person could be a criminal and
two the police could have done something
wrong
which tends to be more often the case in
these controversial cases but in any
case
that's not even the myth making i'm
talking about the real myth making is
the attempt to rewrite the evidence in
the case
to now suggest that this shooting of
dante wright was not an accident
it was in fact on purpose so for example
you have the the and of dante wright
speaking publicly
and saying this was not an accident it
was outright murder
now we showed you the body cam footage
yesterday the woman literally yells it's
a female officer she literally yells
taser taser taser shoots the guy that
says oh my god i shot him
it's gonna be hard to come up with
better evidence of of accidents than
that
but here's the ant suggesting that his
murder anyway
did y'all not see my little great nephew
did y'all not see that beautiful baby
he is fatherless not over
[Music]
okay um i'm sorry it was not murder
it was a tragedy it was a horrible
circumstance and the woman is going to
end up
probably copying the manslaughter but
that was not murder
okay and and aoc is saying the same
thing because again the idea is that
evidence is unnecessary in order to
declare that the police are really bad
so
aoc the the incredible
brilliant insightful fresh
faced so fresh so face alexander
ocasio-cortez
famous mostly for being very popular on
twitter she tweeted out dante right's
killing was not a random disconnected
accident
oh it wasn't really explain it was the
repeated outcome of an indefensible
system that grants impunity for state
violence rewards it with endlessly
growing budgets at the cost of community
investment and targets those who
question that order
okay that is just insane i'm sorry
that's that's crazy
when she says that dante wright's
killing was not a random disconnected
accident which is exactly what it was
that it was the repeated outcome of an
indefensible system that grants impunity
for
this woman's to end up on manslaughter
charges rewards it with endlessly
growing budgets
at the cost of community investment i
wasn't aware that when you
actually invest in the police that
doesn't count as a community investment
considering that the
single greatest factor in reducing crime
rates is putting cops on the streets
and targets those who question that
order weird because aoc questions that
order
and i'm not seeing the police pulling
her over and or doing something
terrible to her i'm not seeing that then
she suggested
cameras choke hold bands retraining
funds and similar reform measures do not
ultimately solve what is a systemic
problem so she's saying that you can't
even take
actions that are likely to reduce the
likelihood of bad circumstances
she says the system will find a way
killings happen on camera people are
killed in other ways retraining grows
money while often substituting for
deeper measures
so what exactly is her solution
presumably defund the police
and then you want these people deciding
what is best for
for you and your community it's pretty
incredible stuff
speaking of which the officer and the uh
and the police chief
in uh in brooklyn center have now
resigned
so again the notion that the system is
completely it's a complete failure
and that this particular incident is
evidence of the complete failure of the
system
the body cams gave you the evidence the
body cams are what
let you know what happened here the
information was released to the public
doesn't matter the the point here from
the media from the democrats is that the
cops are always bad
the cops have to be stopped the cops are
a rampant fascist force
out of control and the only undergirding
so much of what democrats talk about
cops is this
they have this bifurcated view of cops
on the one hand they will they will pay
homage to them the same way that joe
biden paid homage to a police officer
who was killed at the capitol
yesterday and they'll do so in moving
fashion on the other hand they will
suggest that america's police are
systemically racist
and it all depends on the circumstance
but
in the end can you trust democrats to
keep your city safe i'm wondering
because what i'm seeing right now is the
democrats who run
every one of these major american cities
are not keeping you safe they're making
your life worse
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the latest in the derek chauvin trial
because if you're worried about the
riots right now in minneapolis
wait about a week we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are a smart and decent person you need
life insurance protect your loved ones
by getting life insurance with policy
genius
if you need a positive experience to
balance out all the negative in your
life consider protecting your loved ones
by going over to policy genius they can
help you compare top
insurers in one place say 50 or more on
life insurance
once you find your best option the
policy genius team will set up your new
policy for you
and answer any questions you have along
the way you can feel good knowing your
family has financial protection getting
started is super easy first you head on
over to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
and you can compare quotes to find your
best price since their licensed agents
work for you
not the insurance companies there is
zero hassle if you had any speed bumps
during the application process
policy genius will take care of
everything for you that kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across thousands of reviews on
trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool handling of paperwork
the unbiased advice totally free to use
policy genius can promise you won't
leave their website feeling foolish
because you'll leave with what you
needed
namely a great life insurance policy at
a price that you can afford you could
say 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes feel good knowing if something
happens your family's taken care of
policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important
to get it right okay so this brings us
to the latest in the derek chauvin trial
so the derek chovin trial continues to
pace the defense began laying out
its case yesterday and it was
basically two pieces of of
testimonial evidence that really
mattered in the defense case with regard
to derrick showing yesterday now listen
if i have to ballpark where i think this
is going i don't think there's a chance
in the world that shoven actually gets
acquitted
i i think that given the nature of the
jury the fact this is taking place in
minneapolis i think it's very doubtful
you you need a unanimous jury to either
convict or to acquit so i think the most
likely outcome here is a hung jury i
think you'll get a couple of jurors who
say we're not going to convict on the
basis of this evidence
you might get a conviction on the basis
of manslaughter i think the murder
charges are way too far i think they
were always way too far i think
manslaughter
is at the very least somewhat
understandable coming from the jury
maybe if you view the evidence through
through a very skeptical prison toward
the defense
okay but i think the most likely outcome
here is a hung jury
so there are two pieces of evidence that
were trotted out yesterday with regard
to the chauvin trial
piece of evidence number one was this
old arrest in 2019
because it looks a lot like the arrest
that happened
in 2020 with regard to george floyd an
arrest during which he died his behavior
during one
is sort of indicative of his behavior
during the other the other piece of
evidence
was a bunch of testimony from a police
use of force expert named barry broad
who basically testified that chauvin's
use of force here was reasonable
okay well that is what the defense needs
to show broad's testimony i will say was
was not
stellar the the body cam footage from
the 2019 arrest
is more probative okay so we're going to
go through all of that because remember
what the defense has to show here or
what the prosecution has to prove in the
fantastic debunk
is one that that floyd died of
not a drug overdose or any underlying
condition but died because of what
chovin did
and two the defense the prosecution has
to show
that chauvin's use of force was
objectively unreasonable
that it was unlawful okay so the defense
has to show contrarily
that not it's not beyond a reasonable
doubt that it could have been reasonable
use of force and two
floyd could have died from these other
causes okay that's what a lot of the
test
testimony was about yesterday okay so we
begin with
with the 2019 arrest
there there were a couple of pieces of
testimony here that actually mattered
one was the actual body cam footage from
the 2019 arrest
in which it it was shown in court that
floyd had swallowed evidence when he was
arrested presumably drugs that's what he
swallows and it wasn't like a bag of
cash
he swallowed some of the evidence and
the idea here presumably
is that floyd could have done the same
thing here that as the cops were
approaching he put a bunch of pills in
his mouth those pills that drove up
his heart rate and then drove his heart
right down and then he died
right that would be the case that the
defense is making here they're saying he
did the same things in 2019 it just went
a lot more wrong
in this particular case and there's some
ancillary evidence to that effect namely
that there were spit out pills in the
back of the cop car
that were laced apparently with
methamphetamine here is the the
flashback 2019 tape
uh from george floyd's arrest back then
all right come here okay put them on
there on your head
open your mouth spit out what you got
spit out what you got i'm gonna tease
you
okay so he obviously was not complying
with officer orders there he tried to
swallow the evidence
and so what the defense was claiming is
he did the same thing here michelle
mossing was a paramedic
in that particular case and she said
that i talked to floyd and floyd said at
the time that he was addicted to pain
pills and he took seven to nine percocet
that is a lot of percocet gang right
percocet is basically just oxycontin
here's the here's the paramedic in this
particular case
he told you that he swallowed some pills
right yes
uh approximately seven percocet
correct
[Applause]
i documented yeah seven to nine
every 20 minutes or so for a while so he
told you that he
had been taking those pills throughout
the day right
yes and he i asked him why he said he's
because he was addicted
okay so the the drug addiction case is
going to be a case that is pushed pretty
heavily by the defense
in terms of the causation again there is
an intervening cause they're going to
say the intervening cause was floyd's
dramatic drug use the intervening cause
was floyd's heart condition now one of
the things that's happening here also is
the prosecution is forcibly attempting
to suppress witness testimony
so the defense argued in front of the
jury
guys his drug dealer was in the car with
him the prosecution could offer that guy
immunity in return for his testimony
they won't do it
why do you think they won't do it could
it be because he's about to testify
that he is complicit in the death of
george floyd
by giving him a bunch of drugs in the
car because why else would you have your
drug dealer in the car with you
right so that's something the defense is
arguing they're also pointing out that
there's other testimony
that this guy had for example an fbi
interview for like an hour and a half
and none of that testimony is being
admitted in court
there are going to be some cases on
appeal here the judge's behavior in this
particular case i have to say
is extraordinarily pro-prosecution not
only did he allow a week of testimony
of a very little prohibitive value
promotive means actually goes toward
proving the case he allowed a week of
testimony from bystanders talking about
how upset they were by floyd's death
which is not probative in any way it is
just prejudicial
not only did he do that not only did he
reinstate a third degree murder charge
that certainly does not fit the elements
here not only did he refuse the
the defense's request to transfer the
trial out of minneapolis where it's very
difficult to get a fair trial
but now he's basically barring the
defense from
asking questions about excited delirium
to prosecution witnesses he's borrowing
the defense
from from being able to admit testimony
from the drug dealer who was in the car
with george floyd
you know oh that seems frankly
extraordinarily pro-prosecution okay so
the other piece of evidence that came
out in the chauvin trial yesterday
was uh the police use of force expert
his name is barry broad i don't think he
did a fantastic job frankly
um he was trying to argue that chauvin's
use of force was justified
and there's a good case to make that his
use of force was justified here was very
broad
saying that chovin was justified in his
use of force using a three-pronged
analysis
so was the officer's use of force
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect
objectively reasonable correct yes
so in terms of your three-part analysis
did you apply that analysis to this case
i did in your opinion was this a use of
deadly force
it was not and can you just briefly
overview your
opinions in this particular case i felt
that derek chauvin was
justified and was acting with objective
reasonableness
following minneapolis police department
policy
and current standards of law enforcement
and his interactions with mr floyd
so the three-pronged analysis that he
used to determine this he said
if the officer had justifications to
detain the suspect which he did how the
suspect responded to the officer
and if the officer's use of force was
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect it's that
last one
whether the officer's use of force was
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect
that's the one that's really at issue
because it's clear that floyd was
resisting arrest
it is clear that the officer had
justification to detain the suspect
because the suspect
was passing counterfeit bills and
resisting arrest the real question is
whether
chauvin was justified in keeping floyd
face down and then staying on him
as he passed out here's broad explaining
why he thinks they were justified in
keeping floyd face down in the first
place
why would it be safer for the suspect to
keep him in that prone control
because if they were to get up and run
handcuffed trip and fall sustained
facial injuries
other injuries on the ground their
mobility is reduced
their ability to move is reduced and the
ability to hurt themselves is reduced
what if they became sick for example
prone control
instead of having somebody lay on their
back where they could aspirate on vomit
prone control their face is down
airway is clear if they vomit it's not
going to go down their trachea
down their throat okay so that's
actually a pretty good piece of
testimony in favor of the defense that
what chovin was doing here is basic
police protocol where the where this
witness
you know really screwed up is he said
that that was no use of force and when
you're suppressing floyd by being on his
back that is a no use of force that of
course is very silly it is a it is a
form of use of force
it is just a very low level use of force
is what he really should have said and
the prosecution of course jumped on this
with both feet
a compliant person would have both their
hands in the small their back and just
be resting comfortably
versus like he's still moving around did
you say resting comfortably
or laying comfortably resting
comfortably on the pavement
yes at this point in time when he's
attempting to
breathe by shoving his shoulder into the
pavement
i was describing what the signs of a
perfectly compliant person would be
so attempting to breathe while
restrained is a
being slightly non-compliant no
no okay so so there the prosecution is
honing in on what they think is the the
defense use of force experts
overstatement of the case what the
defense use of force expert was
attempting to say presumably
is that if floyd had been compliant all
the way throughout he would not have
been kicking at the officers
he would have not been attempting to
push against the officers who had been
lying there and then they basically
would have just been
either sitting on top of them or not
sitting on top of them at all
okay here's the bottom line again the
defense does not have to prove that
chovin is innocent they just have to
prove beyond a reason
not beyond a reasonable doubt the
prosecution has to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
so we'll see what the rest of the
witness testimony tends to show
again my guess is that chauvin ends up
convicted of manslaughter if he's
convicted of anything and a hung jury is
a
not implausible outcome in this
particular case if there's a hung jury
that'll be rioting
extraordinary rioting if he's convicted
of manslaughter there may be rioting
because people will just say well he
should have been convicted of murder and
this is how the media has set up this
narrative
even though the evidence here is quite
shaded even though this is a much more
complex story than people were
originally led to believe
the media have set this thing up for
riots and riots you shall receive
because we now live in an america in
which
police killings that are unjustified are
statistically extremely rare they are
very very rare in the united states
given the number of interactions between
police
and suspects but you know what is not
rare whenever there is a controversial
situation caught on tape or even not
caught on tape between
a white police officer and a black
suspect
you can be assured that in at least 50
percent of cases
i would imagine there is some form of
rioting or looting that breaks out into
the public
if it's high-profile enough that
whenever one of these things becomes
public
there is writing and looting and we we
should not live in a country where we
expect that sort of behavior because
american citizens have a right to expect
two things that don't conflict with each
other one that they are not going to be
unjustifiably
killed by the police or mistreated by
the police and two that their fellow
american citizens
should not be allowed to roam around
looting and rioting
and doing great violence and harm these
are not conflicting
ideas they're perfectly inconsonants
with one another but the media have set
them up in complete
opposite to one another because the idea
is that if the cops do something wrong
then riots and looting if not justified
are at least understandable and that's
the way the media have been covering
this stuff throughout
that is the soft bigotry of low
expectations it would not be allowed
under any other rubric in american life
but the media have basically decided
as nicole hannah jones said 16 19 riots
already coming up we're gonna get to
the perversion of tess heinz under joe
biden and the democrats they've been
told science
they're just guided by the science yes
there are 1 million 200 thousand
33 genders but they are guided by the
science
on everything the science rules except
when
it's super political we'll get to that
in just one moment first
let's talk about the fact that you
constantly need to make your business
better if you're a business owner who's
hiring you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person for your role that's why
hiring can feel like trying to find a
needle in haystack
you know you could post your job at some
job board but then all you can do is
hope to find the right person if they
come along
that's why you should try zip recruiter
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top job sites with just one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them
to apply in fact zipper crew is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with wage many options ziprecruiter
finds you what you're looking for the
needle
in the haystack right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this web
address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire again go to
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire we use it here at
daily wire because we are constantly
seeking better employees
not just to threaten our current
employees with the possibility of
unemployment but also just to increase
the possibilities of our business
ziprecruiter.com dailywear go check them
out right now
alrighty it's already episode five we
still cannot get enough of kenneth owens
or her new show candace if you haven't
checked it out yet i don't know what
you're waiting for
candace hosts a lively series of guests
every week for discussion panel
interviews my favorite is her signature
cancel corner
this week she'll be hosting comedian and
podcaster adam carolla
he's a terrific dude good friend tune in
because you don't want to miss their
conversation the show streams on fridays
9 p.m eastern 8 pm central at
dailywire.com you can get the audio
podcast canvas on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcast so
if you need some candice owens in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a 5
star review if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the left the democratic
party the media they've decided to
pervert the science on every possible
front we'll get to how they are screwing
it up on the vaccines in just one second
because it truly is one of the great
public
health failures of our time i should
note at this point
that the scientific community has
basically become in many ways a
propaganda outlet on behalf of the left
this is true
in regards to everything from
transgender hormone therapy and surgery
for children
to climate change it's pretty incredible
there are two problems that plague the
scientific community
when it comes to politics one is the
ultra crepitarian problem i've used this
word a lot because
uh frankly i see it everywhere now ultra
crepitarianism is the
the thing where you speak out of turn
where you don't know anything about a
particular topic and then you speak as
though you do know something about a
particular topic
ultra crepitarianism for example would
be the cdc director rashel wolenski
declaring that racism is a public health
problem
which is absurd it's like saying
stupidity is a health public health
problem
it turns out lots of bad things in life
have impacts on public health that does
not make them a public health problem
it's that is ultra crepitarianism she's
speaking outside her area of expertise
while using her white coat in order to
guide her ignorance
okay so that is one problem the other
problem you see is the reverse effect
where politics cloaks itself as science
and then people treat it as though it is
science right what i call the bleed over
effect
which is a bunch of people suggesting
unscientific things
are in fact science this would be joe
biden suggesting that gender ideology is
in fact science when it clearly is not
okay so you see both of these things
from scientific american
scientific american has become more and
more politicized these days
they openly endorsed joe biden for
president it was
not a complete shock but you saw nature
do the same thing a bunch of these
quote-unquote scientific magazines
suddenly have a very strong political
bent who could have predicted such a
thing
okay there's a piece in scientific
american in which the magazine announces
that they are no longer going to use
the term climate change instead they're
going to use the term
climate emergency now i was not aware
that there's a scientific designation
that amounts to emergency
there is such a thing in medicine for
example there's like emergency medicine
right which is the person is going to
die if you don't do something about it
right now but climate emergency
it's not as though a certain level of
climate change occurring over the course
of the century
turns it from just change to emergency
this is a completely political
designation
and by the way i do not consider it a
quote unquote emergency
if the climate were to warm four degrees
celsius over the course of the next
century
i consider that a gradual change that
human beings are going to have to adapt
to
with increased technological know-how as
well as innovation
which human beings have been doing for
literally all of the history of
humankind
adaptation we're really good at it
mitigation not so much
in any case scientific america now says
that it is a scientific duty
for them to call this a climate
emergency which is just a lie it's just
a way for them to
create a certain level of alarmism that
is unjustifiable
by the facts on the ground the fact is
the economies around the world are
growing at such a rapid clip
that the the amount of damage to be done
to humankind on the basis of climate
change
is a small percentage of global gdp on
an economic level
and in terms of actual human damage we
should be focused on how to mitigate
that human damage but we are not talking
as so many people have suggested about
billions of people dying or hundreds of
millions of people dying or anything
like that
we're not even talking about tens of
millions of people dying we're not
talking about probably millions of
people dying
through climate change directly in any
case scientific american has now
declared a climate emergency they say
it's an emergency it's a serious
situation that requires immediate action
when someone calls 9-1-1 because they
can't breathe
that's an emergency when someone
stumbles on the sidewalk because their
chest is pounding and their lips are
turning blue
that's an emergency both people require
help right away
multiply those individuals by millions
of people who have similar symptoms and
it constitutes the biggest global health
emergency in a century the covenant 19
pandemic
now consider the following scenarios a
hurricane blast florida
a california dam burst because floods
have piled water high up behind it
a sudden record settings cold snap cuts
power to the entire state of texas
these are also emergencies that require
immediate action multiply these
situations worldwide and you have the
biggest environmental emergency to set
the earth in millennia
climate change
okay that is just an absurd comparison
that's absurd
hurricane's been hitting florida for a
very very long time and as it turns out
actually the amount of damage being done
by hurricanes has only been increasing
because of what we call the bullseye
effect namely people are building more
stuff in the way of hurricanes
a california so you're going to you're
going to say there was a cold snap in
texas
therefore climate change is an emergency
i was informed
reliably by you guys that weather is not
climate
in fact every time there's a cold snap
there are people on the right they're
like oh climate change isn't happening
because it's snowing and people left
like hey
you're confusing weather with climate
i'm sensing a similar thing here hey
look bottom line is this is not
the science it is science right it's
fake politicized science and you see
this now being applied
in the realm of vaccinations i've never
seen the sort of public health debacle
that we are seeing
from the biden administration in terms
of their public facing statements
toward vaccination these vaccines with
regard to covet 19
are a godsend you're talking about
vaccines that have a nearly 100
effective
efficacy rates with regards to reducing
death and serious disease
and your take is nobody should ever go
to a restaurant
again and not only that your take is
that if there is an upswing it is so
dangerous we have to shut down all of
american society but
if we have a vaccine in which there are
six adverse reactions among seven
million people who have taken the
vaccine we have to pause on that vaccine
you can't have it both ways either
covers an emergency or it needs an
emergency
right now all of these vaccines have
been given emergency use authorization
they are not operating under typical fda
rules by the way the notion that the fda
is your great protective body is an
absurdity
it's an absurdity from the beginning you
know when we had
the actual sequenced vaccine ready
the sequencing of the vaccine was ready
in january of 2020
not in american so far as i am aware had
died yet when we had
the the sequencing available for the
rmrna vaccine for covenant 19. it took
all the way until november
for the fda to clear the use of these
vaccines how many lives could have been
saved in the meantime
the cdc lied to you about mass then the
cdc blew it about eight times over
for a variety of reasons and your take
is
that the government knows what they are
doing here okay so the latest indicator
on all of this the latest move
on all of this is that the the biden
administration has decided via the fda
to halt the rollout of the johnson
johnson vaccine the johnson johnson
vaccine
is a dna based vaccine as opposed to the
mrna
vaccines which means it is slightly more
traditional than the mrna vaccines
it also happens to be extremely durable
because dna vaccines don't have to be
stored
at 30 degrees below zero or whatever it
is that you require in order to actually
store the the pfizer vaccine for example
also they're a single shot vaccine so
these things are really really useful
especially when you need to quickly wave
them into a community
and have the shots rolled out which is
what you need right now for example in
michigan
instead the biden administration's fda
and it is the vitamin administration fda
they announced that they are pausing the
jnj vaccine because there were six
six cases of a serious blood clotting
disorder
that emerged after 6.8 million people
had been given the johnson johnson
vaccine your chances based on these
statistics
of having this condition are less than
one in a million
we stopped the rollout of vaccine in the
middle of a pandemic right we're not
talking about like just generally
in the middle of a pandemic by the way i
would imagine that the rate of
guillain-barre
for the flu vaccine is way higher than
the rate that you are talking about
right now
in terms of the the number of people
with adverse consequences
and yet we don't pause the flu vaccine
roll out in fact you have to agree with
that
okay but here was anthony fauci the
greatest doctor in all the land after dr
joe biden suggesting we're not being too
hasty and pausing i mean what's the big
deal we have other vaccines that are
ready to go as we'll see in a second
it ain't quite that simple here is
anthony fauci
you want to make sure that safety is the
important
issue here we are totally aware that
this is a very rare event
we want to get this worked out as
quickly as we possibly can
and that's why you see the word pause in
other words you want to hold off for a
bit
and very well may go back to that maybe
with some conditions or maybe not
but we want to leave that up to the fda
and the cdc to investigate this
carefully
so i don't think it was pulling the
trigger too quickly oh it wasn't pulling
the trigger
it's all fine joe biden then came out
and he said well you know we have these
other vaccines that are ready to go they
can just ramp up so johnson johnson
ramps down
no biggie my message to american people
on the vaccine is i told you all
i made sure we have 600 million
doses of the mr not
of either johnson johnson and or
astrazeneca
so there's enough vaccine that is
basically a hundred percent
unquestionable for every single solitary
american
yeah that doesn't mean that they've all
been rolled out evenly right according
to mitch smith and michael shearer over
at the new york times quote
the student union had been converted
into a vaccination center the doses had
arrived on campus the first appointments
were minutes away
then at 7 23 am on tuesday news of the
pause and johnson and johnson
vaccinations reach
youngstown state university we are ready
to go said shannon tyrone an associate
vp at the university in eastern ohio
who instead started calling students to
tell them they would not be able to get
the vaccine after all
similar scenes played out across the
country as the abrupt halt in the use of
the j j vaccine because of concerns
about potential blood
clots upended plans to vaccinate some of
the country's hardest to reach
populations
in california mobile vaccine clinics in
rural areas were canceled in chicago
vaccination events for restaurants
employees and aviation workers were
postponed indefinitely
at colleges in ohio new york and
tennessee where the one dose vaccine
offered a chance to quickly inoculate
students before they left campus for the
summer
appointments were called off on mass so
no you can't just cancel this thing
and believe that it has no immediate
impact it does not only does it have
immediate impact it completely undercuts
the entire case that you have been
making which is that people ought to get
the vaccine in the first place
you keep saying that vaccines are safe
then you roll this thing out and on the
basis of six cases
out of seven million people got in the
vaccine you're going to tell people that
we were pausing it
okay there are a bunch of people out
there right now who are worried about
the fact there's no longitudinal studies
on these vaccines
what do you think you just did you just
completely undermined faith
in one tool that is going to get us out
of the pandemic in the first place
it's a bleep show this isn't the science
this is tough science and i can't
imagine it has anything
to do at all with the apparent desire of
the biden administration to prolong
the pandemic indefinitely to continue to
play down the efficacy of the vaccines
so that we can continue to proclaim that
we're in the middle of a crisis and
require giant government action in order
to get out of it
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content we'll
be talking
about joe biden withdrawing from
afghanistan we'll talk about
new information about andrew cuomo who
is apparently like super anti-semitic
like really
like i have a line from andrew cuomo
here it's pretty astonishing
a lot more to get to later today so make
sure to check it out in the meantime go
check out the michael knowles show on
today's episode michael we'll be talking
about caitlyn jenner
seriously considering a run for governor
which would make caitlyn jenner what the
first
female governor of the state of
california i'm not aware that
california's had
a female governor before that episode is
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a blm supporter defends looting cruz and
hawley move to bust up
corporations and the cdc pauses one of
the woofloo
vaccines check it out on the micromoles
show
you